es ist die absolute katastrophe und wenn
es so weiter geht ist sie unausweichlich
eine kettenreaktion an deren ende die
zerstörung der allermeisten satelliten
rund um die erde steht das ganze nennt
sich kessler syndrom und würde das ende
der raumfahrt bedeuten und noch
schlimmere raketenstart wären dann nicht
mehr möglich alles was ins all fliegt
würde zerstört werden können wir diese
katastrophe noch aufhalten
jetzt in klicks zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen in darmstadt in
hessen ist gerade die bisher größte
fachtagung weltweit zum thema
weltraumschrott zu ende gegangen
veranstaltet von der esa der
europäischen weltraumbehörde und das
ergebnis ist ernüchternd finde ich laut
esa chef johann dietrich wörner ist das
wichtigste ergebnis das weltraumschrott
eine globale herausforderung ist
na ja da hätte man vielleicht auch so
drauf kommen können und dem flora
weltraumschrott experte bei der esa ist
der ansicht dass allein die
teilnehmerzahl schon ein großer erfolg
ist da drängt sich doch der verdacht auf
dass die latte etwas tief liegt wenn wir
weiter so schnell vorankommen dann ist
die katastrophe vielleicht unaufhaltsam
dass kessler syndrom immer wieder
schlittern wir daran vorbei es gab
bereits 200 kollisionen im orbit der
erde und jede produziert wieder neue
schrottteile inzwischen geht man von 166
millionen trümmerteilen aus die um die
erde schwirren
wir sind im moment quasi zeuge eines
kessler syndroms in zeitlupe
spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009 stoßen der
usa sind nummer 33 das iridium
satelliten telefonnetzes und der
russische satellit cosmos 2251 zusammen
bei einer aufprallgeschwindigkeit von
rund 40000 kilometern pro stunde bleibt
von beiden satelliten nichts mehr übrig
außer rund 100.000 schrottteilen sie
haben jetzt die chancen für die nächsten
unfall deutlich erhöht und das könnte
zum beispiel eine kollision mit da ss
der internationalen raumstation sein wie
hier am 24
2012 ein schrott teil der kollision
dieser beispiel satelliten steuert mit
hoher geschwindigkeit auf die iss zu es
stammt vom russischen satelliten kosmos
2251 die nasa kann eine schwere
beschädigung der station nicht
ausschließen für die astronauten gibt es
nur eine rettung 2 an die iss angedockte
russische sojus kapsel
im fall der katastrophe könnten sie
sofort abdocken und zur erde
zurückfliegen
die nasa beschließt die besatzung in
diese kapseln zu evakuieren
es waren bange 30 minuten und das
passiert immer wieder die nasa rechnet
also ganz konkret mit einer schlimmen
katastrophe bis hin zur vernichtung der
hss also sie kann sie nicht ausschließen
bereitet sich deshalb darauf vor in
darmstadt wurden jetzt regeln besprochen
und möglichkeiten zum entsorgen von
weltraumschrott
doch das klingt nicht wirklich konkret
satelliten sollen in zukunft spätestens
nach 25 jahren zurück auf die erde
stürzen oder sie sollen sich auf eine
friedhofs umlaufbahn bewegen auf der sie
nicht mit anderen raumfahrzeugen
korrigieren können doch was macht man
mit dem schrott der schon im orbit ist
es drängt sich der eindruck auf dass
eigentlich niemand konkrete schritte
unternehmen wird es scheint so als ob
die weltraumagenturen befürchten auf den
kosten sitzen zu bleiben wenn sie eine
effiziente methode entwickeln frei nach
dem motto macht ihr das nochmal über
geld redet man nicht diese zögerliche
haltung könnte uns zum verhängnis werden
man kann nur hoffen dass bei der
nächsten konferenz konkretere ergebnisse
erzielt werden ansonsten heißt es leicht
bald arrivederci satelliten bei gss und
auch wiedersehen raumfahrt und noch
etwas gps internet internationale
telefonie und so weiter das würde alles
noch sehr eingeschränkt funktionieren
wir würden um jahrzehnte zurückgeworfen
werden
es wäre eine riesige katastrophe für die
gesamte zivilisation ja sobald ihr dann
doch mal fortschritte erzielt werden
werden wir natürlich ein video dazu
machen
und wenn er zu diesem thema auf dem
laufenden bleiben wollt dann seid ihr
hier genau ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst das an der glocke nicht
dann werdet ihr auch immer
benachrichtigt wenn ein video online
geht bis dann bleibt kann